hey reject nation Greg Alvey here I have
with me today
Megan McNulty she was my acting teacher
when I was in acting class where I
learned to become an oscar-winning
performer megan has a YouTube channel
now called the tiny tutor we have a
surprising amount of subscribers who are
parents but I thought yeah still worth
having you wants to I am a tiny mama and
I've been a tutor for 18 years
it's a place for parents to find trick
I'm just coming up like this on the top
of my head it's tricks tools and
strategies for early reading and math
development I'm not reading this I'm
reading this like they're fragments from
a tiny mama who's also a seasoned
private tutor I think I need to go back
that this is the tiny tutor and go back
to acting class today so now to pick up
a line and say a really adorable cute
Channel her daughter is adorable her son
also adorable she's adorable
it's just a whole adorable channel where
we actually learned some stuff I even
learned snow actually trying to teach
you parents and help you really quick
easy fun stuff for parents like I don't
know what to do with their homework
they're not maybe I don't know what to
do I'm gonna tell you it's pretty
awesome stuff I highly suggest you guys
go show her some support follow her on
social media and everything Megan have
you ever heard of a channel called bad
lip reading I have never heard of a
channel called this is you're in for a
treat right now you're familiar with the
Royal Wedding yes in fact I woke up at
3:00 a.m. with my daughter who's on my
channel with me to watch it she was so
into a dude if I didn't wake her up
she's gonna be so mad at me I suggest
you put on those headphones and I gonna
show you a new channel
so how many animals would you say you
probably do absolutely 1693
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends dog food doesn't feel so
gross to the starving man if you want a
hot dog then you gotta cook a hot dog
what put it on the stove she won't
does it help you to eat this Wiener
thing I don't think that it does you
know I fell into a coffin this weekend
no I didn't it was just a dream just a
dream
there wasn't a coffin
I said hooray and do you know what I
felt like like the best this all true
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my god what did you think of bad lip
reading okay here's the thing
I normally don't like random I always
say in class in acting class random
isn't funny yeah that random was so fun
it's crazy how they're so good at like
coming up with these words and look like
here's what they could be saying so it's
that's literally their mouths like I
watched it that's yeah yeah I know
they're not altering their mouth at all
that they do it for movies you could
watch this there's music videos and
stuff it's life as a parent is hard I
need this in my life it sounds like they
might be saying yeah why and I just love
the way they splice it together in that
like silence with Harry and William at
the end like amazing yeah you watch the
whole Royal Wedding until they got in
the carriage and then we went back to
bed I mean we were exhausted what was
more entertaining this or the actual
Royal way I mean come on Axl Rose I'm so
happy to have introduced you to that
part of my enjoyability of watching this
we'll see you my god I do not like that
present it is a fail your puppets I
think the best part about the randomness
is that they still carry the
conversation that's the thing there's a
true light and there's actually some
point and you and you're like actually
it's really that are going back and
forth and they're replies it's not just
random words that are saying it's like
they have full sentences that are having
a conversation within the randomness
there was actually a thematic yeah
that's brilliant so glad you're able to
watch
thank you bad lip reading together
another great video you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell please make sure
to check out Megan's channel the tiny
tutor people he learned some stuff
especially if you're a parent you're
gonna love it
check
our own personal Instagram and sugar
acting real see what TV show she's been
on some fun stuff there
meg McNutt tiny cheater yay Meg McNutt
tt-that you have to any inappropriate
words this far